inside a touching private memorial
service for Prince Prince's ex-wives
Manuela testily me and my ta Garcia
organized a private memorial for the
late iconic singer on Wednesday in
Beverly Hills the location and details
were kept secret only Prince's closest
family and friends were invited but et
has images from inside the celebration
of life was star-studded
reflections were given by Tavis Smiley
Nile Rodgers and Spike Lee while jazz
artist Esperanza Spalding performed
other notable attendees included Gwen
Stefani Larry King modeled Dita Von
Teese and singer and a fantastic
in late April an official memorial
ceremony was held at the singer's
Paisley Park Estate prince's family
released a statement regarding
speculation of any future memorial plans
that read in part quote there has been
no Memorial funeral or tribute service
for Prince that was organized or
authorized by the family or Paisley Park
representatives together the family is
planning an official memorial service
and public event to take place in the
near future